in Nicaragua Suri Martinez was an
economics professor Regina Roscoe worked
at a call center taking calls from
English-speaking customers both are
young mothers who say leaving was
difficult but necessary because the
political violence in Nicaragua was too
dangerous for their children I was about
to go to one of the protests and
everything like they were starting to
shooting to everybody
we can't return to our houses we were
driven away from a home that my family
had sacrificed for years to have
Martinez says her father and Indigenous
leader was imprisoned for opposing
president Danielle Ortega after some of
her students were killed in
demonstrations she took her two-year-old
daughter and fled for the U.S paying off
gains along the way and arriving at the
bridge to El Paso
there was an unending line of migrants
from many countries yeah but my daughter
was very sick so people let me pass to
the front U.S border agents treated the
child for pneumonia and released them in
El Paso she and her mother are now
recovering at a shelter run by the
Episcopal Church These are people who
will do and have done anything for their
families
these are the kind of people I want as
my neighbors U.S authorities are
processing and releasing about 2500
migrants a day in El Paso
some are sleeping on the streets as they
wait for buses out of town even as
temperatures drop below freezing
when we arrived at the border between
Mexico and the United States and turned
ourselves in it was a huge relief that
we were finally out of danger the worst
was behind us
for all the people you see here who have
been granted temporary permission to
live in the U.S while they fight for
their Asylum cases many more remain
waiting on the other side of the Border
in Mexico they had hoped that the U.S
would relax border pandemic restrictions
this week which would likely have
bettered their odds of getting in but
now it appears that will not happen at
this time the U.S Supreme Court has
temporarily extended the Restriction at
the request of republican-led states
that say they can't handle more migrants
coming the state of Texas has sent
additional soldiers to guard the Border
our Wish isn't to invade anyone is to
live in a country where we have the
right to work to live a dignified life
to be free from oppression the Biden
Administration wants Congress to approve
three and a half billion dollars to
secure the border and provide
humanitarian Aid
meanwhile the migrants already here say
they're that much closer to their
American Dream
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera El Paso
Texas